Morty and I just one line reference you
in live now
yeah pseudo kind of pre-show on Rob's
channel we're not officially alive yet
right now because we're all sitting up
multiple streams but here's your intro
Rob's channel for you people I'm Betty's
a countess Torian that is Rob the vape
King that is Sal the Lord and Master the
weekly poll that is Faust the prettiest
man in the world and that is Joel the
unofficial official fifth member of the
Whig people there I gave an opening I
like how you have a capital W and a
capital I learn how to spell bro get on
my level what I do you spelled with
wrong where it's not my capitalization
is wrong it's not Meldrum is capitalized
stuff why you gotta be a pain in my butt
make sure you put the little tag on my
chats to look at it on Twitter it's like
I'm good
oh yeah you want to say Chad is located
on Twitter we don't have everyone trying
to chat in nine locations yeah you know
what that oh yeah that's true I did I
guess I could just disable like comments
cuz then like Oh that'd be like what the
[ __ ] bro we don't you to be pretty we're
right on your hands Oh YouTube extreme
keys now yeah yes they've had for a long
time oh they haven't how do i how do I
put it like how do I put a thing on here
like I know how to put an annotation on
here you gotta do it all you got to do
it on this side you got to add text I'm
doing right now oh okay okay okay
text I'm doing right now oh god it's
huge that's what you said oh man perfect
timing
what what is the weekly pool just gonna
become a morning zoo show where we have
all those sound effects ready to go the
walls and the
smells jobs now that I threw your job
now your you know no that's what you're
being brought in to do you're being
brought in to be our sound effect to be
the morning zoo guy that's fine I I mean
like I've almost considered doing that
for the weekly poll the fact is like
what was it there's another there's a
there's a competitor podcast that I
can't even really call a competitor
anymore because they don't update
anymore
I wouldn't mention their name cuz
fuck'em but no it is oh no no all right
fine it's called comic dorks on the Frog
pants Network what the hell is both of
those things it's actually a really fun
show but they don't update anymore the
robit
hashtag Rob core did this gonna be like
super entitle people on my channel
they're like no Rob you don't do that
over it certainly you do that over here
and some supers you have super entitled
fans Rob well I use like I used to have
super entitle fans then they all got ran
off because your opinions stop being
listened to I've never listened to the
opinions of my fan base they'll be like
you know I really feel it'd be a really
good idea if you did like 1970s Marvel
superheroes and no I know I am I had
there was an episode of I guess in like
a live stream of coming to coffee was
always like I'm just doing videos and I
like I'm stuff that I like nas is all
there is to it yeah there's no there's
no discussion here guys there's no
debate I got a comment today because
someone left a comment on one of my
videos and I replied to them but like
there was a comment in between that
where someone was being super rude and I
was applying to the rude comment and
that person removed the rude comment and
then someone else obviously couldn't put
two and two together and today was
responding like um I don't like the way
you talk to your subscribers so I think
that I'm going to leave this channel and
it's like okay bye boo bye your audience
to be able to see it in a moment
yeah ready everyone get ready nice
freeze-frame
do a cool freeze-frame
what freeze frame this is getting ready
no okay so there was there was one guy
who come who left it left like this
Internet can totally see you now there
was one guy who left this crappy comment
and like like he just wasn't prepared
man like he got 50 wait I gotta do my
live thing over here ready welcome to
the weekly comic story an audience is
probably like one person that one person
feels so special right now especially
when you will reply to their comments
there was there was one guy who who
posted who posted some comment and I
can't for what it was but he got like he
got like 50 comments worth of hate and
yeah yeah like what was he said he was
oh he was oh I uploaded that Dragon Ball
Z video no and and he was like he's like
if you don't like if you don't just
study if you don't start doing anime he
just took the comics like I'm leaving
and I'm like it's one video a week bro
you'll be fine and you'll live
he started fruit you know he was he was
like what and then like after that it
was like takes like 50 or 60 people who
were giving him [ __ ] and then he just
tucked his head in the sand he was like
well I'm just gonna mute this and then I
posted reply I was like what did you
think was gonna happen on my video and
the guy goes it goes I'm Ali every
turtle in her justice and every spotted
with so you thought they need to load
the video of the valiant to tell me that
hey here's one for like again you guys
probably obviously getting shitty
comments on YouTube that's just par for
the course
how many death threats have you guys
gone and about 20 I've never gone
Kathryn okay yeah I'm doing pretty good
like I'm about 5 like our mean and mad
they've gotten way more than me and
usually the ones I've gone are they're
really more mad at them but they
couldn't get to them so they said it to
be yeah yeah yeah oh oh my god I can
monetize and I can add cards I'm adding
cards yeah come on man no way you're
never like you money what the hell are
cards and why does you jus want me to
use them because they're getting rid of
annotations Oh which gun sucks cards
work on mobile devices it's the same
thing as an annotation but it's great
that they create an industry and
they force you to use the only tools
that are available and then once you've
integrated them into your video so you
like 600 videos using their new tools
they throw them away and then replace
them something else so your tools so you
so you literally can't even use the
interface so you're like you're watching
the old video from like a year ago and
you're like cool click the annotation oh
there aren't anymore and now you're just
like oh you got that I at the end card
bars I have a fancy end card that shows
videos right yeah the Kinkos anymore
that's the end of it I recently have
been watching like a bunch of old school
youtubers that you swatch back in like
2011 and there's so many there's so many
that like had some like 500,000
subscribers which was a big deal back in
2011 and so many of them just were out
there peak and then went hmm I'm done
and they're just not okay maybe we
should stop preaching this and actually
talk about something this isn't the show
oh right this is kind of up with you
anyways all right guys what are you
overcoming story inside you all know me
I'm betting the comic story and this is
our weekly poll podcast that we do every
week and yes it has been very slow but
updating a SoundCloud in iTunes in yes
we are tearing the guy who's supposed to
be in charge of that a brand new
[ __ ] in terms but I am Benny
becoming story if you want to know my
guess on my wheat channel technically
guess right now no we will not get an
alert when you go live yeah then why
they ask me how long has it been like
we're not gonna do this often we'll
probably like every other week do a
multistream but if you want to catch it
every week and all of the additional
podcast make sure you go over to twitch
on all of our twitch TV backslash a
little monster that is where you can
subscribe to the channels and stuff like
that all of us do streams over there
faustus moving a on hiatus anime and
Rob's doing gaming and Rob is having a
good time
to the twitch side and you subscribe you
do get emotes of all of our faces I'm
signed in as Benny alright so anyway
guys I'm Betty the comic story and I
know I have funny names on them so let
me reintroduce the entire crew here for
everyone who's joining us on Rob's
channel and on my channel and on the
twitch side Benny the comic story and
you all know me that is Robbie comics
explain I'm sure you know him cuz we're
on his channel also but the guy that is
currently flagged as sal or lord and
master of the weekly pull depending on
whose size you're looking at it is sal
from comic pop mombi prettiest man in
the world or Faust from it's super
Factory depending if you're watching on
my side or Rob side is faster but super
effective and joel is one of the 90
people that run comic book cast it
literally is like the white house man
there's like some blaze like five people
that was an office space where he was
reported like five managers I wanna ask
a cool question fouls did you cross 100
kegs I didn't catch any notification who
did I'm five hundred subscribers away so
you're watching on Rob's channel or
Benny's channel it's super effective my
anxiety for the record house it'll be
rather embarrassing if my gaming channel
surpasses you and gets to 100k before
you could that's at ninety nine thousand
so we're both in a race right now
okay okay guys seriously please first
one there has to buy loser a coke yeah
but you know Fran what are you from
England I'm from England
okay I like iron Bru iron brews great I
am Bruce and if I had y angling for the
first time like three or four months ago
oh yeah how was it it's pretty good okay
topics are if we haven't done this in
two weeks now because I've been gone you
guys did it I think last week but it was
like a weird one we haven't had all of
us here in two weeks so today we're
gonna talk about the current landscape
of comic books which is the changing of
Marvel its Secret Wars
what's going on with DC you things are
being changed we're already getting rid
of Superman truth and we're gonna close
out the podcast my
regaling us of his exploits at fanox
look we all want any rid of super injure
you didn't know what that time you dude
it's the best Superman story like
they've done in my twenties and I agree
and I love the fact that it's in four
different books and it's like here's how
this would be taken this is what
happened here here's a give that I love
that following Superman truth is the
current Superman storyline it was
supposed to start a new era of Superman
he lost his powers he's still like
superhuman but he's not he's Golden Age
Superman is what he is
yeah but speed tall buildings more power
certain genes well DC's in the red and
they've said that all of these extreme
stories are gonna be ending in the next
issue or two so they can get back in the
green innovative to much more
interesting innovative too much yeah we
innovated too much guys reel it back we
gotta get to meat and potatoes which
they doesn't saying we gotta get back to
meet it was a story about Superman
that's interesting why would you kill
there's so much you could do with that
it's at the same time I will say the fan
base who's not buying yeah that's gonna
say especially if a new reader comes
along they want to see Superman Superman
t-shirt and they're just a bit like and
I agree and I agree and that's the
problem but what I don't understand is
with for Superman titles and for Batman
titles why can't because they've said
continuity is at the window right now
hey why can't one just be normal
Superman Superman be normal Superman
while Action Comics and Superman Batman
and you know those can all be truth and
the same thing with Batman we can easily
have Batman is Batman but all those
other books they're about Robo Batman
that's the thing that's the thing that
same continuity doesn't matter at the
moment but they're essentially doing
what they did at the start the new 52
where they said continuity doesn't
matter and then it ended up mattering I
actually never debility that's the fact
is like no matter how badly you want to
keep your new readers or bring in new
readers with your new continuity those
new readers become present reader has
become old readers they were like
long-term fans like and they're gonna
like it's like the ultimate universe
everyone they create the ultimate
universe they're like look and no one's
gonna age and we're gonna keep it kind
of like within
every year will be like two months I
think and and everything will be
different interesting it'll be like a
New Britain they'll bring in new readers
who have like a whole move a whole new
vision of Marvel and they get to enjoy
that whole corner of Marvel and after
like two or three years it had its own
continuity but because they created it
in 2000 they were like ham-fisted comic
book fans who who invented it and
maintained it so they were like oh no I
don't know how to maintain it and then
they collapsed it with a tidal wave and
then every like literally a tidal wave
every three months they were like oh
ghosts will just join invent it like and
they just couldn't handle it man like
and but even then they were like look at
all this carnie buddy we can't figure
out like either let it happen or reboot
every every year my they listen you will
drown yeah you see and fight against the
current man okay here's I mean like
every problem that we were talking about
last time even one has continuity we're
talking about continuity issues here was
the issue that we talked about like a
fourteen-year-old kid says hey I'm gonna
start reading commerce because I saw
Iron Man 1 and it was awesome where I
support members in Superman it was cool
like I want to start reading comics you
know ever some mom that wants to buy um
for a kid like they walk into a store
and you have one title where you got
Superman with a shirt with the s support
you can have Superman that was pretty
hilarious I'll be that guy in the band
who wears my own band
I love hell wouldn't it have been
hilarious if Superman had worn a Batman
shirt and anyway anyway it's funny side
to funny side w while we keep
interrupting Rob The Punisher where's
Hawkeye shirt half the time or his uh
organs like I'm daredevil shirt yeah
exactly but like it's funny cuz DC to
actually reference like superhero shirts
because of the beginning of the new 52 s
first on the Teen Titans there is
literally a frame of Tim Drake holding a
Batman shirt kind people actually wear
this stuff super disgusted because like
in a world where there really is Batman
it's kind of like it'd be like if we
were like a Phoenix Jones shirt
back to my point the problem with DC
fill and continuity a blunder was this
if you were reading do you see comics
since even since the new 52 or before
then like you're just like cool because
I know what's going on if you're going
in by now
and you didn't you never read futures in
which being drawer talking about that
earlier today you shouldn't it doesn't
matter you know but if you never ate any
of that some of you have no clue what's
going on you're gonna walk into a comic
book store you're gonna see Superman and
t-shirt and jeans on the cover of one
one one comic or I guess actually have
Superman and then you're gonna turn and
open up Justice League and you're gonna
see Superman in a cape and a red and a
blue outfit and you're gonna be like
what the hell's like what's going on
like what how did they fit in and that's
too much and they don't like people want
to know like how does this how does one
tie into the other how does it work you
know and that's what that's what drives
people and say like yes you know it's
it's and I think that's exclusive to
comic fans and fans in general we are
fastidious people and we want all our
things to make sense but you want to
have it by higher that's nerds in
general because like I mean even if
you're like even if you're a Doctor Who
fan and not a fan and I know Faust is
gonna say like oh you mean you're
English because like there's a Doctor
Who fan over here it's just people who
watch TV institution for the YouTube
people I'm resetting the YouTube side
because I'm having issues of dropped
frames so just say if you're watching on
YouTube it'll be back in a second okay
yeah but yeah like if you're a Doctor
Who fan like you have like you can a you
can pick and choose your continuity
because either you're gonna watch you're
gonna you're gonna care about the
continuity from 1969 or whatever or
you're gonna be like it all started in
like 2003 like or whatever the hell they
really like me yeah exactly like or you
even start with any doctor like you
could just be like oh you know I'm gonna
start we're during the tenant years or
I'm gonna start during the guy past
years that's what everyone says I don't
like that show so like but the point
being making up on Ross out I'm sorry I
don't only doctor but like oh my god man
the most recent promo for doctor who has
made me not want like the David Tennant
promo from sci-fi and from BBC America
over here in America where like David
Tennant does that whole monologue where
he's like I'm the doctor and I'm 903
years old I'm like that's cool I'm in
and then I washed I'm like trash cans no
thanks we just made a lot of friends
online there say okay I have no secret
that I'm not a fan of doctor but like
there's there's the new promo with the
old guy from like who's a real actor but
is unfortunately not very good yeah and
his hold that hold like it's this
dramatic music that goes I'm the doctor
I save people I'm like what like so you
could really you could literally use
that for like I'm a firefighter I save
people I'm oh I'm a 911 operator you
tober yep what a dud this out there to
all American Doctor Who fans the general
consensus of Doctor Who over here is
it's for nine-year-old boys that's our
business cards isn't it comic book
youtubers professional man like we make
videos about comic books it's pretty
friggin sweet isn't it amazing we are
the definition of man we read comic
books for a living style you just
offended all firefighters in our chats
great you're cooler than the doctor
that's what I'm saying
nobody is cooler than the doctor
firefighters not even the doctors cooler
than the doctor but anyway yeah like the
continuity is inevitable and continuity
is like what weak I mean like history is
continuity yeah we create continuity by
accident it's true we need somebody we
create real continuity on purpose by
challenging documents in history we win
a war you can wreck on your past odds
are made by the winners aren't European
Elvis just had several crises America
Americans had at least one crisis I know
of but like you know anyway that's when
we reset that the continuity we didn't
like having you know a north and a south
thing we wanted a one whole thing so we
merged all of our continuity this is an
ultimate America this whole time just
didn't know that's kind of the kicker
you know is because somebody was like
there's somebody ask me what I did when
I finished stop death of the family and
I was like the next one will do with
Batman is in game somebody was like are
you gonna do futures in and I'm like
nope you know and they were like well I
was like well because feed because do
you see came along they said hey guys
you want to see what things will be like
in five years then like read this story
and it's like wow there's gonna be
really cool that like well actually you
know and that's the problem is is you
know and that's what kind of kicks me
but but for me I think for people in
general like people want like people
have this inherent desire to know where
things fit in like everything has its
place like it has to belong somewhere
and so they see two versions of Superman
or if Jim Gordon's Batman in one comic
and Bruce Wayne sitting on the Mobius
chair in another comic when I said well
this doesn't make any sense how do these
you know this bad dog don't bark you
know this is something the problem is is
not it's not it is so much like see
Marvel and DC both said oh we're gonna
do terms of continuity and it's gonna be
super confusing a super convoluted and
they and they thought it's because
everyone didn't want continuity they
just wanted stories but when in fact is
everyone just wanted less convoluted
continuity we wanted to be able to sort
it out and not be like DC explained to
me he'll draw Batman's had five Robins
in five years want less convoluted
continuity I think it's that they mean
the proof is in your subscribers the
proof is people just want to be in on it
they just want to hook it they don't
care if it's convoluted because there
because people are smarter than we give
them credit for or they think they're
smarter than they really are
either way they want
- no they don't kill Heidi said the
greatest ever yet well I had the
greatest idea ever for both comic book
companies first page you just have a
timeline of the character that you
picked up and where they fit into
everything that's that's literally what
they did with the Star Wars novels hmm
like the Star Wars novels and Dark Horse
Star Wars comics had a timeline and a
geofence bubbled and where your story
fit in within that continuity well what
the fact is the good I'm I've been
saying for years now they should have
certain difficulty levels on the comic
books saying if you've been reading
comics for a while this one's probably
if you're new beginner novice know like
the fact is what I think you need to do
with continuity hope we lost Joel is I'm
looking at I'm looking at the chat but
like the point being the solution for
continuity is simply this I think here's
just don't you can't stop it let it go
and when key because like the problem is
real the real reason why DC and Marvel
are like oh all new when we got a reboot
in [ __ ] is because these movies are
bringing in new readers write like you
rub your example of Iron Man like people
seeing Iron Man yeah first of all
Iron Man sales boomed but I remember
when I aren't like what stories were
going on during that time and Matt
Fraction was doing like extremis and
[ __ ] and like that there's no like I
tried it I was like ooh you know what
these movies are pretty cool I'm gonna
go read Iron Man I could not get into it
to save my life no like not only could I
not really get make head to tails where
we were at that point but I did not like
the story or the characters or like
where was go and I was like this is
awful like nothing the book is awful
just like this level I can't I can't get
into this damn character and the movie
made it so easy for me to do that but if
there had been an original graphic novel
or a reprint of an essential story that
the publishers had I don't know timed
around the same time as the release that
would allow me to get into the story
like read an essential story or get into
the character without having to mire
through the and then allow me to ease
myself into it gradually that maybe that
would have been a way to do it and so
rather than like having DC have a crisis
every frickin five years which is what
they do and like in fact the crisis is
I've noticed have gotten more frequent
in shorter map to time like crisis on
Infinite Earths you know you had like
what 50 years of continuity 60 years of
continuity and then after crisis on
Infinite Earths you had friggin doesn't
count but it's zero hour which is like a
which is like a soft reboot and like but
that was 28 years and then Christ was
like five and brief and then flashpoint
was like another five years like the the
the timeline for which we need
continuity reboots kept getting smaller
and smaller and it's like you didn't
even get a chance for this place to
breed yet like its new 52 this universe
was four years old there's an auntie
monitor he's back and he's gonna reboot
the universe again or maybe not I mean
like home or maybe not you don't know
but like you can't have this and why not
just let the continuity keep going like
do whatever start from zero or start
from pre whenever let it go let the kit
let the people tell their stories and
when Batman vs Superman comes out
you call up Geoff Johns and somebody
great and you say draw me Batman or
Superman like a like a like an original
graphic novel that we put out that we
have control over that like and and it
seeds different ideas that we like to
play with continuity or play with ideas
that are in the DC Universe happening
right now and then people who want to
get into comics or who are playing the
idea it's right there on the shelf comic
book stores will play with that comics
comiXology will jump on board but
they'll put them front and center so
people like oh there's the thing I want
that's like the movie I saw and then
they buy it
and they buy it for $20 because that's
how much it nerds know graphic novel
it'll be and then they go to the store
and they go hey while I'm here like it's
like friggin Little Shop of Horrors like
whoa what's that strange and interesting
plan on the window and while I'm here I
guess I'll work buy $50 with the roses
like while I'm here I guess I'll buy
like
and guess what we're you going for $50
in roses what you took it well alright
Little Shop of Horrors set in like the
50s so like $50 with roses so you do
realize your cameras dropped out right
yeah I know yeah if you realize that
you've been like slowly but surely
degrading as you're landing and at any
rate your internet and everyone's crazy
nearly killing you it's like I'm running
fun I would say to me for the dual
stream but everyone else is fine um I
guess my whole opinion on continuity in
terms of marvel alignment with their
current reset with Secret Wars is I
don't mind resetting continuity if
you're gonna do it in a way that
genuinely feels like someone had a great
idea for a continuity for them to go
into like resetting back to issue number
one or issue number zero is it's just it
just seems to be done constantly people
money and I don't like that at all
yeah they need money but at the same
time find other ways don't do a
continuity reset because you're pushing
people that were reading comics out of
comics and doing is just doing new
number ones every number every time a
new story art comes up you name the
comic that and make it number one and
then everyone will know there's kind of
died especially since like the only
reason to do the number ones back in
like the 90s it was beat was because
people were collecting them like now the
collection for college funds is dead go
with what I'm I won it's like just and
they threw out the window all of the Oh
detective in action have been going on
forever you know like they're up to 700
they get rid of that well you know that
was a big problem like in the nineteen
that's why I like Marvel went bankrupt
because you have some collectors booms
and people were like I'm gonna buy this
comic and hold on to it forever and not
let let like the market oh hold on a
second hold your thought real quick bro
I'm guys in the YouTube I'm gonna end it
the Train like because we're losing
everyone now and we're dropping frames
so if you want to keep watching the
podcast check us out at which this was
an experiment to see if we can dual
stream yeah I can't do it on my thing so
I apologize to all of you guys the comic
story and YouTube side please go check
out the twitches in the description down
below you can join the chat there I'm
gonna lose I'm gonna drop it off the
YouTube side though because I'd rather
have a clear
video over at the twitch side I'm the
host next time we do this maybe Sal
should host the twitch side while I do
beeps idea all right
thank you guys I'm sorry we'll be back
soon huh
okay I just I kept losing frames and
everything was degrading yeah no I was
drunk everything on my computer just in
case it was me what did I just drop off
twitch and everything okay but like fast
you made an excellent point where it's
like if you're gonna reboot your
universe you better for a damn good
reason like you better of a damn good
story and like as much as I might not
necessarily agree the Marvel needed a
reboot Hickman's story while you know it
might you know some people might not
agree it's great some people might not
agree that they like it a lot of work
effort time thought has gone into it a
lot of talent has gone into it and it
came from the germ of a great idea and
it naturally progresses through like a
threat of logic that was that was you
know natural and organic and so as such
I'm totally on board with this Marvel
reboot whatever they want to do with it
through Secret Wars because honestly it
kind of feels like the crisis on
Infinite Earths which was a great idea
that a bunch of really townspeople had
that they given led to more more
interesting mythology cuz for me like
comics are you know much like for Grant
Morrison you know comics are like modern
mythology and you know what a great you
know what would a great idea whatever
image of the crisis you know I mean like
the idea of like oh well you know we
know what this word means in our culture
in our
terminologies and ideologies we're like
crisises mean that like things got so
effed up or so complicated it needed to
like things needed to change I think
it's cool I love the idea that like that
Marvel is actually at least Marvel isn't
gone I'm like okay we need to reboot
everything like heroes reborn remember
heroes are born oh no it's coming out I
can't wait for it yeah no not that show
I mean like oh this show is amazing who
does anything here
I'm really excited for you talking about
the 1990s I'm talk about the first try
for alta marvel where they were like
well we just want to see what Gimli and
Rob Liefeld would draw the Fantastic
Four so here that was just a cash grab
like that was there was no story really
- like motivate them to do that they
create a story around it but it had
nothing
it wasn't like someone said I have a
great idea and here's what we're gonna
do it was I want these creator or these
artists who are making money over on
their side of the fence to come back on
our side of the fence and make us more
money with with with Secret Wars you
know rebooting everything this is from
Hickman being like I was really good
idea and yes it might reboot the
universe but if it does it's because
this means something that's cool so
here's a kicker though like and that's
that is that is such a good point cuz
here's okay daredevil is a really good
example because I was thinking about
this when I was making my video the
other day then I was going through the
different like right and daredevil has
three reboots basically like three main
reboots character courts patisserie you
got his introduction
you've got the Frank Miller reboot and
then you've got Jeph Loeb coming back
with daredevil yellow yes and singlish
sending him back to this to the status
quo is it a reboot because yellow was
that a continuity no there do we always
a reset of his continuity it was it was
saying like this is like we're sitting
near doubles or those color those color
books are not reboots those are just
those are just out of continuity
re-imaginings of their origins like
spider and blue is not a reboot of
Wednesday sees origin it's just it's
just taking an idea and then giving it
to us well no question that he used your
double yellow to set his origin story
back after great Miller to say like this
is this is the original origin lazes how
daredevil really came about okay
I mean I could be wrong I mean I guess I
am but I don't think you're always wrong
your channel is nothing but incorrect
information everybody who's on that
channel should actually just go
subscribe to Sal Foust than me let's do
that order yeah we'll just set off the
Rob bomb and it wasn't one of your
sundry you don't matter of fact when I
get done with this he's gonna close it
all now
or by the way the idea of rough you know
but can you but you YouTube you know
YouTube keeps coming up with these awful
ideas here's a great idea donating
subscribers bring subscribers you just
click you know the amount of subscribers
you want or you can select them hand
like you know by hand and then just
transfer them to different channel I
think that's a great idea
could you imagine that doki's just
sitting down there was Rob you're like
oh yeah and they're just one day comic
pop stops you're oh no it's not unlike
getting a new dentist you know what I
mean like or going to the doctor's
office and going like hey where's my guy
and it's like oh he retired here's your
new guy and it's like whoa I liked my
old guy you're gonna like this new guy I
guarantee you but you're basically
stating is that you're better than Rob
and all the people should unsub and then
subdue you . they should unsub and i
think a lot of tamar dual-sim not I am
no no that's not how YouTube works you
understand when somebody subscribes to
somebody else's channel it means they
stop they stop subscribing to yours yeah
yeah no you got it wrong Rob the way
YouTube works is you're allowed to have
one in each category
you only have one comic youtuber but you
can have a gaming youtuber 11 player a
blogger there's only a few of them
anyway like three gaming youtubers
there's only like like you it's a really
small place when you get down to it
knows so Rob your point about daredevil
being like okay okay so assuming that
I'm wrong then then kind of going with
that the factory know that the question
is asked which Daredevils right
Stanley's daredevil Frank Miller's
daredevil like so on and so forth and
that's that's kind of issues when you
look at characters like but the overall
the overarching point that I was making
was that writers change characters in
the context of the story they want to
tell you know and then frame was like
well I want to make a darker daredevil
so let's make him talk you know Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby that daredevil was a
reflection of the sixties characters
were more lighthearted back then and
they were you know in the 1980s you know
during the Bronze Age whatever they want
to call it you know it's written by an
uber conservative or written by yeah
like like characters change over the
years and that's the issue is is you
step into this world when you get into
comics where you look at the entire
history of a character and you see
varying changes you see different things
taking place and so reboots aren't
inherently big or an inherently good
thing because they give people a place
to start fresh and that's kind of the
the problem that people have with
reboots is because I think people get so
caught up with a singular character that
they say well I don't want to see them
rebooted and that's where things have to
be done intelligently like DC for
example the new 52 reboot was a great
idea I love the new 52 reboot because I
said okay I want to read DC I can start
here and it gave me a place to get in
because I hadn't read DC really like I'd
read it's spotty I hadn't read DC
consistently for decades you know a long
time and then and then you guys were
like just read new 52 star from there
it's issue number one should be fine
except for Batman and Green Lantern
whatever so it was like okay it was a
great place to start at and the problem
was I think DC kind of jumped a gun in a
few ways like Barry Allen was a real to
get an example for reasons that I don't
understand they said Barry Allen's a new
flash you had Wolowitz you've been the
flash for 20-something years 26 years
people I guess man but the question is
like what are you gonna make the stuff
fun you're gonna make some fun with
Geoff Johns loves are you gonna make
stuff on what like who's like whose
opinion or whose care whose version of
the character is the right one and the
fact is the no one's and everyone's like
you by the fans behind Jon Stewart and
the reason why the fans behind Wally
West is because of the cartoon shows
those the actual ones the actual comic
book fan favorites Barry Allen has
always been like the epitome of flash
just like how George always been up here
to be a good lad rebel it depends what
generation of comic book readers you're
right because Michael is from my
generation especially like people that
started reading in the early 90s
Wally West was the flash Barry Allen was
this other dude that died if not a guy
oh yeah Wally West our best-case
scenario Barry Allen was like the martyr
flash the flash like gave His life to
ins to save crime like no that's cool
you know so you know you get that but
like that
it's kind of it it wasn't like you
wasn't like you know old school fans or
fans from like the 80s and 90s we're
like my favorite value at Barry Allen
stores are here here here and here no
it's like I know of Barry Allen but
Wally West is the flash to me that's in
the sinuses at the point that I was
making like if you assuming that you
watch the show like if somebody sat down
and they said well this justice league
is a really really cool show like I want
to read more about the flash if they
went to a comic book store they were
buying Wally West because that was the
ash that was being though that was the
flash you know that's the version that
was it was the only flash you saw Barry
Allen from time to time but Barry Allen
did not have a flash series he was gone
and so the issue that I kind of thought
was was a little silly I'm I wouldn't go
as far as to say that they were wrong
per se but the thing that I thought was
kind of silly was to remove their
continuity and to say Barry Allen's the
flash again when you had people who have
been reading Wally West for 20 years
then to not not even have Wally West in
the new 52 when it launched and then
when he finally did get introduced and
when he did finally get introduces that
wasn't the character it doesn't matter
that you had a race change or whatever
his personality is totally different and
you know a little rat let's talk about
that let's let's talk about that for a
second I was pissed when I saw that when
I saw the Wally when they brought Wally
West back yeah I was so mad and people
people asked you know so first of all
were like why are you so mad about Wally
West and I said because Wally West is a
caricature Wally West is a depiction of
how people perceive a person to be you
know I don't care about the kid being
black gonna be black whatever we got a
black out in America I was like let him
you know like I didn't matter to me the
problem is it wasn't you a black kept
America but you want a black Steve Roger
yeah you'd have a but the problem is
they introduced him as well he's some
kid from the hood who's gonna run his
mouth and you can't tell me what's work
oh yeah where everyone's used to his
jokey but Wally West no it's not even
that like to me it's it's I wouldn't go
as far as saying like it's a racial
thing but to me like I look at that and
it's like that's that's a stereotype is
what yes that's why I look at that and I
see that as a stereotype and it kind of
irked me a little bit but then again you
know I was I was never reading the flash
and so to me it wasn't it was a like
no outrage there was a freaking out like
oh my god difference bad if this is
different and different is bad because
it's not like it we used to be you know
but like to me was it was a caricature
that I just didn't really care for and
that's that's what kind of drove me up
the wall but having said that you know
me to me you know like I said I'm with
salad fast on this one I think reboots
are a good idea because they give people
a fresh place to start they give you a
zero and a weasel forward this being
said about reboots um with the current
Marvel reboot with the new 52 we knew
where we stood with crisis on Infinite
Earths we knew where we stood your
current marvel reboot I don't know where
we stand because all these characters
are still like everything that was
relevant a few months ago still going to
be relevant in a few months time like
they've still got all their memory
everything's gonna so what's the point a
reboot is the origin even if it's the
same origin you retell that freaking
thing so people know what what the story
is you don't bring it old Wolverine old
man Wolverine and then make x-23 know
what you do is you bring back young
marine and you're reintroduced to clone
x-23 you rangy Dussault you know that
like because I'm always thinking of
things in terms of like I know it's a
business but it's also an art factory
like they're trying to make us to give
us stories and and end it it has to have
integrity and so but at the same time I
understand it's a business so like okay
you want to tell your story Jeff you're
a Jonathan I've been fine tell your
story to grieve with the universe and
then you're gonna or or not not you have
or you've had almost a full effing years
worth of for lack of a better term if
you're like let's say that you're let's
say you're waiting right you're like I'm
looking forward to Marvel but I want to
wait until after the reboot so you got a
year of nothing
yeah what is that that's what we've all
run into everyone's gonna why are you
only doing DC right now and no we're not
really anymore like because how owes to
the Marvel is useless right but you have
those books you have those books that
are coming out for all do all-new
all-different marvel some of them are
freaking like into their like threes and
fours already cuz like the all-new
all-different Avengers number one the
preview is in Free Comic Book Day in May
that is
come out into like December so you know
you're not even gonna so clearly there's
been work already put in place there is
at least you have you hope that there is
a roadmap why not like you know those
secret origins books like where you're
like every every bit like before or
after every crisis they're like secret
origins Batman like just in case I'm
sure what Batman's origin is here's a
book with Batman firestorm and someone
else you don't give a crap about yeah
and here's their origins now as it
stands and so you can read this book now
you have your you're on the same page as
even DC editorial with Marvel you could
create a Bible of the all-new
all-different marvel and it's like
instead of keeping it keeping it like
with editorial me like yeah and I'll
only let like certain editors read it
publish the damn thing mm-hmm all-new
all-different marvel comes out you got
like you got 52 new titles or whatever
you want to know whatever number you
wanna pick and also this $60 hardbound
beautifully painted Mike Dell autos art
book that tells you where everything
stands what the status quo is what
stayed what didn't you work with the
editors from Marvel and you say this is
the Bible for the Marvel Universe from
this point forward but this all this
being said with this not being a reboot
does that not just make Secret Wars just
a giant glorified what if what if but
all the tie ins are the what if the
secret war story is just a glorified
siege or glorified fear itself it's just
an event that takes place within the
continuity of Marvel all those tie-ins
are what if books I have with this
all-new Marvel thing the big issue I
have with all of this is they were totus
as it's a reboot but it's not a reboot
is a rebirth as I reboot I feel like
honestly Marvel got cold feet last
second like this whole thing feels like
a setup does iris leave restart it and
they were like nevermind but but that's
marveled they do that every time they
did that in Secret Wars they did they
for every single event they're like oh
this will change everything
we don't know change that
and see that's that's that's the funny
thing to me manage because okay origins
like let's talk about those orders for a
second there are some characters and
comics that are timeless like they
popped up and they'll they'll be there
they'll be there a hundred years ago
Superman Batman spider-man Wolverine if
you kind of want to talk about that
Deadpool for better force there are
characters that showed up and people
will know about them from now to the end
they'll read about them forever though
go back and read old stuff if the new
publications stop because people are
just like their characters that I've
been around for so long and and and I
mentioned that my video my origin story
about Superman I was like you know even
if people don't know the specifics the
allusions timeless and so you know they
know Superman was on Krypton on the
planet blew up he got shot to earth grew
up on earth became Superman
done and done and and they know the
basis the general idea of it but that's
kind of a testament to how you know how
timeless you know again like the awards
the story is and so I think that that
with the idea you know kind of touching
on with outset and what you know what
Benny said that the kicker here is if
Marvel came along and they said zeros
across the board everything gets reset
issue number ones everywhere then people
are going to be like well what if Peter
Parker's not spider-man anymore you know
and that's the problem is because you
you've basically had Marvel create this
big funnel they had this great big huge
comprehensive massive multiverse with
all these characters popping up
everywhere it's like a giant version of
what Joe Quesada did and they said let's
convince this all down through this
little funnel and whatever comes out on
the other side is gonna be what stays
but the problem is this Miles Morales
his story is still the same you wonder
how Miles Morales became spider-man go
back to the ultimate spider-man well
yeah so in a separate universe to
freakin reconcile the speculation the
uncertainty is actually what will drive
sales even more if you just say we're
rebooting in Miles Morales to spider-man
and also there's a spider-man that looks
like Peter Parker people are gonna go
which one spider-man whose but and
they're gonna go friggin buy both books
to find out maybe some people be
outraged that they had to buy two
different titles and to find out one
answer no question they could have read
on the Internet FM because 25% of them
are gonna keep reading the books and now
you have new readers like oh I don't
now they can't out how it is so
frustrating for these guys who have been
in the industry for a hundred years
don't know how to sell [ __ ] comic
books to people well I mean especially
because especially because before Secret
Wars they set up so many things that
were and that would have been right for
stories like at the end of spider-verse
you had Anna and Spyder UK in loom world
being protectors for the being my spider
protectors for the entire multiverse
yeah that's a great setup for a title
oh no yeah we're doing Secret Wars
technically they are still doing that
but in the context of Secret Wars I mean
even Silver Surfer if you like your
doctor whose secret a Silver Surfer book
like he's going on marry adventures the
universe and then the universe ends and
so it's like what are you gonna do with
this book like one of these people gonna
do that was a debate you know because
when I was once I when I was going
through Moscow official-official fifth
member has returned it's been officially
officially back when sorry about that my
friggin router drop the other that my
computer was trying to force like twenty
two updates I mean I'm like no it's
weekly pool time don't you know when I
was going through the calendar from all
those releases and and like in the next
like three and well tomorrow like three
titles from sick of war zones like three
tions title in and the week after that
like you know some more in like a month
after that more and like and like
they're just they're all wrapping up I'm
like well what's the point of last days
like I was like well maybe I'll do
videos on last no it's not really
wrapping up though because we because
it's the main Secret Wars book has been
pushed back and we're getting an
ex-racer so we're gonna be getting new
books before Secret Wars actually the
last days thing is last days isn't
giving us any more information
no like here's what was happening at the
end of the at the end of the world no
I'll speak to why they're always just
fades to what
the only exception of that and as far as
I know they haven't released a new one
yet his Silver Surfer Silver Surfer I
think is the only one cuz we don't know
what happens like he he outruns the end
of the collapse of the multiverse he's
in some weird white space yeah and
there's kind of eternity but kind of not
you know and and that's it like we don't
know what will come actually
like you'll just survive into the
collapse of the multiverse or if you
lose all of our characters are gonna
show up at the end of this whole thing
you'd be like what they miss appreciate
it well the first still exists because
spider-gwen is gonna be in another world
oh well the week we talked about that
last week yeah when people were talking
about like whoa well you know what's
gonna happen I was like I can guarantee
you how this thing is gonna end like
like the energy to be on Durer's is
gonna be absorbed or something like that
it's gonna disperse the multiverse is
gonna come into existence because of it
and that's that's the end of secret wars
we were right about Loki so I feel you
may be right about this like I picked up
Thor's three and I was reading like good
rob was right way what was was robbed
right about rob was saying that the Loki
we see in that book is almost certainly
the Loki who escaped at the end of his
last day series and they even make a
thing where it's like oh this look he
knows a bunch of information he should
know and they say ah we got no
information on this Loki he doesn't seem
to be from any battle world that we know
uh yeah so so that that's that was
that's how I think do it right that's
know I think it was like I mean I guess
like a do last days but last days
doesn't matter now
like it doesn't make it because
initializer oh there are some and I'll
do I'll do the ones that I like like
I'll do Loki I'll do Silver Surfer I'm
like you ant-man cuz it's a 40-page one
issue one issue and it's excellent
yeah this is a one shot and I can you
know purposive you I'm gonna do some of
that some of the battle rules stuff
that's fun like I'm gonna do worth it
where the monsters dwell with always a
good men and women I was going through
some acid in our incentives and it was
did you know it was like what science
among it cuz tomorrow well I guess
tonight I'll probably be working on
feature imperfect so I can have that out
tomorrow cuz future dude future
imperfect the way that Roger Segway
lemnoc I'm sorry okay I'm gonna be
honest they're only three doctor well
titles that I'm actually enjoying
keeping in mind that I'm the type of
reader that likes melodrama I don't care
about massive fights I don't like main
secret was title can everything for you
like the white lines the x-men yeah
exactly and the only three titles I'm
actually reading are giant sized little
Marvel cuz it was so much fun
excellent
I'm waiting for that one to be finished
x-men 92 I'm enjoying as well and
eiffels
because a force is so good freaking
great
she's just killing it with every project
she's nuts man
and that other student of Snyder and now
perhaps the student has become the
master but that's a shocking thing to me
these are the only three battle well
titles that are focusing on characters
emotions and sort of their interactions
with the secret love because secret love
seems like something that would be up
your ass oh you know what else might be
right up your alley the latest issue of
Midnighter has Grayson at him teaming up
I didn't mean it in that way I meant it
in like a secret love it's literally
totally melodrama cuz everyone's like
found sticking to it and I'm like
usually wrong yeah have you read the
carol for cuz that one was that was very
very like I found that I'm not a huge
Marvel well I used to be but I'm not a
huge fan of her anymore but I thought I
felt like carol court it was she's I
felt like it was a throwback to like old
school oh I might like it then because I
liked also there's so many other
characters in there that are not like
captain they're not Taylor suta conics
Carol Danvers I think you might dig okay
because I like Carol right up until
Civil War and yeah because that was cool
until eternal war and that sucked
good god no but they they just try to
use it as a way to boost their Brewster
character in a failed miserably I'm
really diggin ghost racers right now
mainly cuz I dig Robbie Reyes and I like
they keep trying to throw him under the
bus but he's like no dodge you I will
not be thrown under that bus I'm
mistaken here you can't kill me I ain't
going behind the woodshed with alpha and
all those other characters you start in
then killed not me not today son I was
just created recently leave me alone
yeah basically yet no spider-gwen gets
to go off and have fun
and Kabbalah Khan gets to go up and have
fun adventures no one has any time for
Robbie but um no didn't even guys finish
feature and perfect yet yes I did
- was that ending not funny compared to
like where that book started to where it
ended now here's the thing I had the
feeling you liked it much more than I do
I was just kind of like oh really it
really it was I thought it was it was so
cool because it was such a turn like it
was it was such a switch because in the
original future imperfect like paralyzed
if he broke his neck you know they do a
bird thing they do a clever thing with
Rick Jones and the rebel aligns to the
point where I'm almost like weight
without spooling it was this their plan
all along
alright I'm swollen this hardcore man
the coolest thing boiler cast dude you
you said you're not gonna read it
tomorrow so they can skip your video if
they want my god man we're not spoiling
stuff just happy it was it was a it was
a really it was a really really good
ending like I was I thought it was a
great way to end that and I didn't see
it coming but yeah let's talk about the
latest issue of injustice but no see
that's that's kind of the kicker you
know because it's it's it's funny
spoiler warning over here I won't
I won't spoil it so so that's kind of
that's that's the crazy thing is like we
were talking about this before the
podcast and we said that there's some
things that you can do and there's some
things that you just don't have to worry
about you know for all you guys you want
Rob to spoil it he's putting a video out
tomorrow
few hours but the funny thing is like we
talked about this before the podcast
like like Batman like Jim Gordon Batman
like I have to like I had to do you know
quarterly a lot of the owl's death of
the family in game to get to Jim Gordon
Batman you know because that comes out
of in-game you know
with Superman you'll have to do that you
just got Superman origins truth and then
that's it you know Justice League issues
one through six Darkseid war you know
and that's that's that's one of the cool
things about that stuff you know with
with Marvel's Secret Wars the biggest
issue that I have here is that while the
tie ends are cool and the tie ends are
really interesting and Marvel could use
them as a platform they could say the
original Age of Apocalypse didn't happen
this is the age of of hog this is how it
played out or something like that they
could use that for any number of things
at the end of the day you know we're all
comes down to it they may not matter or
they might matter like we don't know you
know I think they're it's a very
wait-and-see approach like okay you
really like a force gets a new buddy hey
you really like web Wars well that gets
a new book - hey that red wolf guy you
really like him don't you in 1872 and I
was just watch as he was already on the
poster he was already honey haven't you
notice that all-new all-different marvel
is the most diversified office trying to
fill a quota alright we need three black
guys one and one after one India with a
Native American we need one Japanese
person we need to have a two gay guys
two gay guys and one lesbian while we're
attitude it's kind of like that
Cinderella movie from back in the 90s
where there was like Whoopi Goldberg and
she was she was married to a white dude
and somehow they had an Asian son like
like the casting director went well you
can be the Asian one and you can be like
you said there is nothing wrong with it
I don't mind female Thor and x-23 being
Wolverine I don't mind you know Falcon
being Captain America I'm just saying I
find it a bit weird that the cast photo
literally looks like the old-school
Power Rangers thing with her like we
have a black one we got a nerd all of
our bases are covered so everybody would
read our stuff now are you a Muslim Miss
marbles for you that's the kicker man
like that's what makes it so wild and
this that's why everybody's you know
we're doing
the times we like because here's the
problem if we skip over the tie-ins and
we don't do any of them and then
suddenly like DC or marble comes back
and they say like they they say like the
new Steve Rogers is a Steve audition
Planet Hulk and you're just like well I
mean I guess we got to play in hope now
not doing the planet hook story I'm
doing the original and and the
battleworld one because Amadeus Cho that
storyline that's where the and did you
did you want a korean-american Hulk
that's over here did you see great packs
interview like when he has again like
they asked him they were like so so you
know what's the whole take with you know
Amadeus joining Incredible Hulk he was
like here's the deal guys when I was
growing up there were some Asian
superheroes but there weren't any Korean
American superheroes so I made one so I
mean Amadeus Cho from the idea which is
Marvel apparently as Marvel's modus
operandi now where he was like I'm not
gonna create an original character that
like we're gonna hope that people just
like him know we're making an Asian Hulk
Hispanic Ghost Rider and a female we're
not gonna make we're not gonna make like
a new character with no hours that's
always be our diversifying so we're not
gonna also have a team of unique
characters who are all awesome in their
own right so we're gonna take others
well it's like friggin like and I feel
bad cuz us because he's been around
forever too and I feel like he's been
marginalized even though they also put
him front centered cyborg like he likes
poor cyborg who's really he could be a
Titan and you might have a movie in 2020
yeah is so weird
cyborg like seven years ago it's like
you only have a series and ant was so
bad no one knows how to write him
there's a reason he hasn't been like a
core member of the Titans in a long time
because he's hurt
he just can't be written well time for
the Justice League to have a tech wizard
at may bring me a cyborg and the first
issue you're like this is gonna be so
please control this from that he's gonna
do this and then like issue seven after
the first arc and now he's the glorified
security guard watching the camera oh
it's gonna save you just really quick if
you wanted to make it bug a friggin tech
wizard who without about changing the
character 100% entire like you could
have made Oracle a member of the Justice
League instead of doing that they could
have also just read Batgirl at Burnside
they remade Oracle and alter it yet but
she's totally Oracle like a thing she's
differently able to even okay that
wasn't that was one of the funny things
I was going through when I was reading
like death in the family and I was cuz
that was sudden you're thinking because
I said I was sending like Benny and and
and sound messages and I was like how
like like like explain to me Batman new
52 and Vinny's like
daolon you got but again he's like that
to the family it'll tell you everything
you know I said okay cool you guys said
it would tell me everything I'm like who
told you that I'm like the bad girl
tie-in came along and I like how
offhanded DC handled that it was like
well I thought Batgirl was paralyzed
they were like surgery in South Africa
said you should really read it it's
actually really freakin good when I
finally said that's crap look okay it
has its ups and downs it wins me and it
loses me like I didn't like the live
wire thing but I'm liking this new Tiger
arc they're doing there's one one be
back so someone just said in the chat
that they feel like Marvel the Marvel
Universe is gaining a lot of young
characters like the future of the Marvel
Universe um I just went through this out
there every five years or so Marvel does
two things they do a lot younger
characters and they do a lot of titles
to try and gain manga readers it's every
five years like you
if I just go together that those
characters will be for costing about in
two years yuck I love the idea of
playing with looking at the future of
the Marvel Universe of like being oh
like as though they'll ever let like
other characters retire or beer but I
love like those attempts like I liked
the Young Avengers I liked The Runaways
I really liked the idea of like what the
future the Marvel you know is gonna look
like but every time I go to the future
and see in the action it it is written
by some hack or it looks really lame
like eyesight the mc2 universe with like
oh gosh a manned juggernaut like an
Spider Girl how like lame and stupid
that looks and how it's just basically
an idealized like 90s version of Marvel
with garishly like color here's just the
worst ideas possible it's like the first
pitch session from Malcolm what if what
if Black Widow and Captain America had a
bit look shut the hell up like but these
original characters I like the idea
being like you guys are gonna inherit
the universe well you know you're gonna
be the future one day and it's like
that's cool how about do that but not
you know don't you know to replace them
but do that somewhere like like is
always the promise for the Titans that
never comes to pass universe man like it
was a universal people aged in real time
and yeah like the Fantastic Four it
eventually became like what was a like
Johnny Storm some chick and they had two
kids and they were like the Fantastic
Four like I didn't see retired if I
could bring it back - cyborg there for a
second you were saying how unfortunate
is that cyborg is written in everything
the thing that I think cements that my
mind more than anything is when he got
overshadowed by the Metal Men during the
forever evil times like where like
Bailey's Metal Men are so cool why am i
reading about cyber don't read more
about the metal than a weirdest thing
ever because they tried to reinvent the
Metal Men cyborg teamed up with them
then you get like knocked the hell out
no like yeah and that was like a cool
like three issue arc and then they
managed like because Jeff honestly now
they're gonna get a mini Benz
womp thing katana and firestorm it's
creativity over continuity not only that
he's not he's made oh yeah I know
they're established how they're gonna be
working on bringing them back but in the
latest issue Justice League Unlimited
they like they got it was funny it's not
really a spoiler for sakes that happened
a few issues ago it's not really a
spoiler because I said it a few issues
ago Justice League Unlimited he went
missing because of like he got absorbed
and so when they finally defeated the
foe Poison Ivy's just like oh he's gone
I'll go fix this with the plants
probably could know here was the funny
thing like if you read Justice League
Unlimited when they first brought in
like they were bringing all the mystical
energies and so they had a Swamp Thing
and then they bring it heard she's like
why did you bring me
you brought the avatar over earth what's
hanging out there like yo H again I'm
still around yeah it was finally that
was a funny kicker to me like I was when
I was going through and I was doing you
know death of the family somebody
commented actually was several people
they were like so we're expected to
believe that like Batman's entire
history from like the nineteen
ninety-three whatever was all the way up
to now happened in five years and they
were like yes that's really nice and I'm
like I'm like well I'm listening and let
me ask you then let me ask you this like
how do you think like Marvel works right
like I need to tell you like Reed
Richards ain't aged that long since he
first showed up like you just write much
the same day it's the classic Simpsons
sliding timescale of well when did this
happen
a few years ago when the Civil War
happened a few years ago
that's one of my favorite things about
like going on The Simpsons that's one of
my favorite things about having like a
floating timeline because the Simpsons
embraces it so well we've got an episode
where Bart was born in the 80s an
episode where I was born in the 90s now
and they're doing one where Bart was
born in the year 2000 like it just works
yes if you embrace it it works yeah you
know it's funny though actually because
they just brought in two new editors to
start working on the CTV Channel right
and so I always explain it to the good
huh oh yeah good flag now guys go check
on a comic story because we're doing all
the new universes for the characters
that are in the TV shows that have those
like short histories so I don't want to
hold video of them and I had to explain
to one I'm at it because I bring you
editors who know how to edit I don't
bring in people who are comic book fans
to bring in right now yeah I could bring
a comic fans all day and I'll get
nothing done but it's true down there
and she's like she's looking at a mall
she's like so what is this Infinite
Crisis in one year later I see and all
these characters I'm like okay you need
to understand DC's had about five
reboots
Marvel has had none so when we're doing
ages of shield
it's a Rhodes it's just a it's a rolling
timeline everything things everything
fits into that but what we're doing DC
every time you see one of these keywords
that was a reboot you know it's funny to
only you finished as oh my god I mean
that's busy though like I like to a new
reader I had to explain that because
she's just started reading the books to
get into what we're doing and she's like
why don't you make a video and I'm like
I did like six months I have to say that
is one of my favorite things about
Marvel though because for my history of
videos make from every week and if one
week including a bit lazy I'll just do
it with mouth because it's just like but
everything does happen I think that
perfectly illustrates what Faust is
saying right there about how the two
companies approach continuity in
completely different ways for Marvel
continuity informs the story for DC
continuity is the story a lot of the
time and some of the best stories like
okay we're gonna sit you down we're
gonna explain to you why this is the
case
man it is such a hat man is such a
hassle dude I thought this really do
when I finished death of the family I
was ready to throw my computer away
that's right I'm ready to shut down
YouTube I was like dude I'm so ready to
go live so I was looking up some
continuity on Rob and the other day did
you know that they're considering in the
official DC timeline Carrie Kelly is an
official Robin now but not only is she
an official Robin they're also
considering we are Robin the sixth Robin
the group of like seven it's more it's
more than six now it's more in the
newest issue we found there's an army
there's like a Lord of the Rings
child army of Robin by CeCe's actual
timeline where they explain all the
Robins because they were doing the 75th
anniversary stuff on that character
they're like 5th Robin Carrie Kelly six
Robin we are Robin I'm like no you can't
count Brown does not count in any of
those no she's in there too well Robin
is one of my favorite characters in DC
don't care what Robin I love them all DC
you don't know what you're doing right
now so the image states that the first
Robin was Dick Grayson and the details
that said that Dick Grayson became
Nightwing that he became Batman now he's
currently agent 37 then we have Jason
Todd he became Red Hood then he became
Nightwing slash and wingman then he
became bad because they count became
stuff yeah they're counting all that
stuff Tim Drake became Red Robin then he
became Batman Beyond not so they're
telling us what he is oh great Stephanie
Brown became spoiler Batgirl then
spoiler again what weights are they're
counting her in the new 52 as well that
she was a Robin I mean I'll link this in
the chat so you team is counted as
Damian Wayne and then Damian Wayne is
Robin then he's counted as Robin son of
Batman like the Canada mystery I think
my god that's a bit of a stretch let's
be
six robbing number six is Carrie Kelly
who was robbing and then ended as cat
girl robbing number seven is the we are
robbing whose first appearance is we are
robbing number one so not even counting
Duke from the futures end and all the
other stuff with Duke previously and
what they're counting is Dax Isabella
Troy Rico and Andre no one else what is
it what so Duke doesn't even get counted
in the thing but but but Duke was the
guy Duke was the one they built up from
friggin like what are you feeling I just
linked it into the dough chat for the
the stream so you guys three of those
lemons I gotta go sorry about Robins
tomorrow I know let's rel it's read
about rums what guys so welcome to the
end of the show we discussed continuity
I think I think ending on the the Robin
continuity issue is a good way to end it
so I want to end it with with found
space on that for the Roberts was I
think he's looking at the page right now
yeah I agree I died wholeheartedly agree
with that Kelly counts as an alternate
Robin no questions
she was never in main continuity over
there one brief appearance in the new 52
this super breathable a funny video game
shifter on that is the official history
of the Robin that is DC that's not like
one of us making a video and counting
them that's DC counting the Robins that
is some selective history yeah that is
some very thank you for joining us for
our discussion about continuity most
likely this will probably be the
discussion for the next three weeks
until things are reboot and then we will
argue about how wrong it is I'm sending
the comic story and that is Rob the vape
King from comics explained that is
salable Lord and Master the weekly poll
from comic book that is fouls to the
prettiest man in the world from it's
super effective and that is Joel the
unofficial official fifth member of the
crew from comic book cast I hope you
guys enjoyed our podcast today we're
gonna go into the post show so if you're
following us on Twitch
whoever can stay we'll just kind of chat
with you guys for about ten more minutes
I know Sal's gonna take off but the rest
of us can chat with you guys know what
thank you guys for joining us make sure
you check out the post show or come over
to the twitch where you can subscribe
getting moto cons of all of us
go check out the weekly poll dotnet it
is getting completely revamped by screen
wave media the guys who brought your
team four star and other things so it's
gonna be an amazing website real soon
one one that we don't have to mess with
anymore oh and make sure you follow our
twitter at the weekly poll go to our
Facebook the weekly poll and you can
find all of our individual stuff on our
individual channels thank you guys and
close your side Rob I'm closing it right
now okay hey